hello everyone and welcome back to
Magnus Carlson's never ending quest to
reach the ELO of 2900 it's a very nice
game from the 37th European Club cup
where Magnus with the white pieces faces
at pental Hari Krishna and I didn't even
have to change magnus's rating as I
messed it up here yesterday uh as you've
seen Christopher you had a rating of
2856 while playing uh but uh yeah sorry
about that uh so let's check out the
game it's a very nice one uh features a
very very nice positional uh moves and a
very very nice pause the video moment so
Magnus has the white pieces and he opens
with C4 he goes for the English opening
sorry about that
ah and uh Harry replies with Ponte E5
The King's English variation G3 by
Magnus with Ponta C6 and now Bishop uh
sorry Ponte D4 striking in the center
and the bishop to B4 we have Bishop to
D2 blocking check Bishop captures Queen
captures and now just Pawn to D6 with
Knight to C3 Knight to F6 in the now
Knight to F6 and now grabbing the full
center with Pawn to E4 we have Castles
by Hari and now there is a game where
Bishop to G2 played it was played in
1992 in the Hungarian championship
between gabrakala and petroleko but here
we have Knight G2 E2 by Magnus and it is
now as of move 8 that we have a
completely new game so here uh what can
Hari do of course he strikes with B5
and it makes it possible even though
Magnus is defending it twice the Knight
is also stuck guarding the four Pawn so
if you want to capture on B5 that's fine
but you can only do it once so Magnus
plays captures captures and now Pawn to
A3 preventing Pawn to B4 we have A5 now
preparing Pawn to B4 and now Bishop to
G2 putting more
um uh putting another Defender to the E4
Pawn so now capturing on B5 is a threat
but instead of Defending it Hari just
goes Bishop B7 and adds another attacker
to the E4 pawn and here Magnus just
castles uh saying that B4 is not a
problem even though you can dislodge the
Knight you will not be able to win any
material but it it definitely is a move
so Hari plays it a uh Pawn to B4 attacks
the Knight we have captures captures and
now just Knights the D5 blocking The
Bishop's attack over the E4 Pawn uh
Knight captures on D5 with e Captain D5
and now Queen to B6
now defending the B4 pawn and putting
more pressure on the center here Magnus
trades off a pair of Rooks captures
captures and now the captures on E5 we
have D captures on E5 and now uh once
all of this trading has been uh
accomplished the material is completely
even uh both players are Rook Knight and
Bishop Rook Knight and Bishop kind of
queen the same amount of Pawns and now
Magnus has a past the D Pawn so uh
definitely white is is to be preferred
here and Magnus just shows us how chess
is played here he plays Pawn to G4
sort of weakening the king side but also
a very important positional idea
stopping any advancements like F5 and H5
and also clearing the G3 Square for the
Knight so once the G3 Knight Knight
comes to G3 then it can come to F5 to H5
to E4 to F6 the well uh many good
squares so here at Knights the D7 we
have Knights the G3 and now Pawn to G6
and while this Pawn to G6 move does
prevent Knight to F5 and Knight to H5 it
also weakens the F6 Square so now Magnus
will just put a knight on e4 and have
very nice control over the F6 Square
Rook the C1 not going uh behind the pass
Pawn but occupying the uh the open C
file Rook to d8 putting pressure on on
the past pawn and now Knights the E4
and now as long as this uh Knight is
here you can't really move the Knight on
these seven otherwise Knight to F6 will
be just uh well devastating something
like D6 happens block the Queen's
defense of the F6 Square Knight F6 Queen
H6 all of a sudden it could all go very
very wrong uh so here Harry just trades
off a pair of knights and Magnus goes
for Knight captures Queen captures and
now this very nice Rook to C5 The Rook
is now added as a defender of the D5
pawn and now the queen can move and go
after the E5 Pawn so Queen B6 attacking
the rook and now just Queen to E3 uh
defending the rook and putting pressure
on the five Pawn okay for the moment you
can't capture it as you have to defend
the Rook but it's very very hard to
Define that they actually find the move
for black so here we have Queen to A7
just keeping the pressure and Magnus
plays Queen to C1 with ideas of maybe
playing Rook the C8 training of the
Rooks so Bishop to B7 taking off the um
C8 Square from magnus's rook and now
Pawn to H4 now Magnus wants to play Pawn
to H5 Pawn to H6 uh grab hold of the
dark squares as they have been weakened
and then put pressure on the black king
So Queen to B6 H5 and now this very very
uh interesting Ponte H6 where you really
have to wonder if it's possible to
capture on H6 because what if Queen
captures okay you lose the Rook but uh
isn't like just getting checkmated it's
a very very cool line that we have to
explore because obviously both of them
have calculated it so if Queen captures
an H6 Queen captures on C5 okay you grab
the Rook H characters f-captress and
queen captures with check King to f8
what uh how to continue this if you just
play Queen to F6 checking E8 and the
King will escape so here the move to
find this Pawn to D6
uh taking away the E7 Square from the
black king and also threatening to pick
up the bishop on V7 and here best would
be a rook captures attacking the queen
queen F5 check King G7 now you pick up
the bishop and now uh the problem is
there's Queen to C1 checking the G2 and
queen F4 if not for this it would be
actually okay to play this with white
but now you don't have any checks you
you kind of have to trade Queens
otherwise G4 is hanging as well and
that's all there is to it once captors
captures happens the the end game is
completely winning for black for example
King F3 uh just Rook D2 you go after the
pawns and now you don't carry if Pont B3
are just gonna check the king capture
here create a pass B Pawn and if King
captures then just captures here with
checking E3 row captures on B2 again
completely winning for black so after H6
Magnus just goes Queen to E3 and here
you have to really figure out uh how to
go about this position Rook the D6 is
best just adding another Defender here
but how to play the G captures on H5
sort of thinking that maybe Magnus will
uh or automatically recapture but there
is something better something that
allows Magnus to push this game for the
win so feel free to pause the video and
try to find this idea while I give you a
couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations I'm not recapturing
or even playing Bishop to E4 as those
are very interesting moves and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is Rook the C8 that's now that's a
move uh uh seemingly offering your Rook
but not really because the black queen
is hanging and the problem is if the
Black Wing captures an E3 oh there's a
nice solution to a rook capture some d8
with check and after King G7 F captures
uh you're just up a full Rook so what
can Hardy play here well he goes for the
only thing uh he does have that's moving
the queen somewhere he plays Queen to D6
he needs to keep an eye on the rook and
now there's a rook captures Queen
captures and now not Queen captures an
E5 but rather Queen captures an H6
showing that capturing and D5 is
impossible because then Queen to D2 will
just pin the bishop and um uh well
that's that's the game the problem for
for Hardy here is the that there's no
better move if you play something like
age captures on G4 Bishop to E4 and now
Bishop H7 will end the game there's
there's no defense against this so after
Queen captures on H6 he actually does go
for this uh
Bishop capture 7d5 move just uh grabbing
a few pawns for for the bishop but now
if if it's winning then it's winning if
it's not it's not so here Magnus plays
Queen to D2 now he will win the bishop
uh H cap krsn G4 and now just going for
Queen captures and D5 uh saying that the
the end game is completely winning for
him uh Hardy does trade captures
captures and that's trading isn't any
any better King G7 now King to G2 Ponta
F5 and now King to G3 we have King to F6
King to H4 and now Pawn to E4 as the
bishop is preventing the king from going
here and the King prevents the black
king from going here so upon to E4
Bishop to C6 with King to E5 and now
just King to G3 again if you push then
King captures and G4 so King D4 King to
F4 King to D3 now King characters on F5
E3 and now just F captures on E3 and the
problem is you can't play G3 because the
bishop covers the G2 Square so that pawn
is not going anywhere so here a king
captures on E3 was played but now just
Pawn to B3 and he was in this position
on move 43 that pental Hari Krishna
resigned to the game as there is nothing
more to be done here a few more moves
can be played for example King D3 you
can go after the pawn but after King
capture sanjifa and King C3 Magnus will
just play Bishop D5 guard his spawn and
that's it black has no moves you can
just uh you know move your King around
the white king will go all the way uh
here uh captured upon move the king and
then Advance the past B Pawn to win the
game so who wins the game of course the
the B Pawn
uh sir uh that's the game I hope you
guys enjoyed it Magnus and his quest to
reach 2900 it's not easy he has two wins
in one draw but still he didn't even uh
gain one full full rating point I think
or they just didn't update it I checked
like the before making the video but it
still says like that Magnus is on plus
0.9 yeah so very very slow progress but
it's you know one one Quest that you can
have for for a lifetime so it's not a
bad one uh so yeah that's the game hope
you guys enjoyed it uh I would like to
wish a very happy birthday to Alessandro
that's not a Alessandro that's
Alessandro so uh I hope you had a good
one and I would like to thank ante Velma
eh music Jose Palacio and Chris Malin
for your contribution to my channel
thank you a lot I really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing to check up on your wonderful
suggestions such as this one and
whatever else happens in the Chess World
so thank you all I will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day